and spencer turnbull will be making his
fifth
start of the season today and the last
two have not been particularly
sharp for spencer but uh that doesn't
mean it won't turn around today i'm
going to pay
particularly close attention to a
on the ground and in the hole it's short
good room off balance throw
nice backhand scoop by jonathan scope
anything to to make him conscious inside
hi hopper for scope two away
the 2-2 swung out and missed down go the
royals one
two three here come the tigers and their
red hot bats
daniel lynch could just just be himself
and go out there and pitch free and easy
forget about the numbers forget about
your pass
but keep the ball out of the middle
in the air to right and solaire
is there and hopefully he's everywhere
today
let's go five for nine in the series and
he belts this one high
and deep to center field taylor going
back still going back reaches up and
makes a nice running catch before
he hits the wall beauty foul tip
and a strikeout
back through the middle and that's into
center field
so the royals add to the air with a base
hit
ready to go the one-two to hearn and he
struck him out big out right there
for spencer turnbull it sure was
first pitch swinging to right field that
goes grossman still going back
he's got it just before the wall stole
extra bases
away from michael taylor who stares down
grossman
miguel cabrera the all-time hitch leader
now for a venezuelan-born player
the 3-2 again swinging a fly ball softly
into right field solaire over and in and
he won't get there
no flare you don't see many of those
from miguel
drops along the first base line
eric haas lines one to right solaire a
late jump
that's going to bounce off the wall
cabrera is going to head to third
haas has himself a one-out double
in his 21 debut and his family loves
every second of it
2-0 on castrol the other way and it gets
by santana
cabrera is going to score they're going
to hold haas at third base
and willy castro drives in the tigers
first run of the day
when is it the corners one out a one
nothing lead for the tigers
jacoby jones the other way and that's
another base hit
the line keeps moving castrol on his way
to third solaire bobbled it that gives
jones a second
and the tigers add to their lead
the 2-1 to center field
taylor has a beat on it willie castro
tags
jones does as well the run scores
jones moves up to third it's a sacrifice
fly for akil badu
bobby grossman batting the 1-1
that's a base hit to left center
grossman keeps it rolling
four-nothing tigers
here comes the pitch on 3-2 and a swing
and a miss and he struck him out with a
fastball
up and that is number four
and you don't want to leave the zone
chasing hits in other words oh my gosh
i'm old for five now i got to get a hit
this time up
that's a rip to left for goodrum a two
out single for nico goodroom
one sharply to third dozier on the dive
and in time to get haas at first base
this is the look right here the
foot's on the back and it's overturned
but i like that curveball i really do
the 2-2 curveball
hot shot to third and one hop to the
glove side candelario fields and flips
o'hearn on the ground willy castro
pivots to get the force at second that's
all they'll get
the 2-2 that was filthy fourth strikeout
of the day for spencer turnbull
ends the fourth for kansas city
and then they got two in the first
inning last night
pulls it to the right side that'll be
through
and that'll get taylor to third that's
the second time today the royals have
had a base runner past second base
merrifield on the ground tigers will
hope to turn two
they do they sacrifice the run
but they turn it on merrifield 1-0
swinging the ground ball to first base
scooped up by scope underhand flip leads
turnbull to the bag
and just like that in the space of three
pitches spencer turnbull gets out of a
jam and gets three outs
the one two swinging the ground ball and
a high chop to the right side a base hit
miguel cabrera will stop at second base
that's the clearest indicator
yet of the all the hard work for nico
gudrum jim
of course 45 still a war year yep
there's a ground ball
short they go second one first base two
that's a double play
nicely done to get [ __ ] and the royals
out of trouble in the fifth
he has a better slider today game for me
slider was spinning in the last couple
outings looks like it's sharper
the one two swinging a miss just a half
cut on another
slider now that that's uh that ball
started off the plate and then went away
that's how far off the plate that pitch
was
i mean the and with salvia at first
here's the base hit to right field for
ben attendee he's three for three
salvi's going to make the turn and he
will go to third
upright relax stands for o'horn tucks
that right shoulder in as he [ __ ] a bad
high over the left swinging a miss
good curveball down he's brought it back
jimmy i just love it that's the yellow
hammer folks
here's the 2-2 on the ground to second
castro retires dozier and turnbull out
of the jam
he has been money hasn't he you bet
spencer turnbull will get to the seventh
inning
a wave and a miss very comfortable a
smooth
90 plus in a season high seven
strikeouts for spencer turnbull today
aj hinch is going to go get spencer
turnbull 99 pitches for turnbull
and he was rock solid here today
cabrera's one for
two today miguel's hit in the second
inning moved him within one of frankie
frisch
42nd on the all-time hit list
swinging a line drive base hit into left
field there he is
tied now at 42. seems like
every hit right now is a a milestone but
that's another one that's going to go
into the history books
for live drives and just beautiful
breaking ball down with down and got it
single buggy whip for the big man and
they've been scoreless
since the seventh inning today
whit hits it hard to the opposite field
grossman goes back and it's going to be
off the wall nikki lopez will go to
third
whit has a double an opposite field hit
and the royals have two on with nobody
out first one then away wit look at that
he went with it and went with the pitch
and drove it with some authority there
santana swings on 3-0
and he is out a run will score so it is
4-2
and the royals are within two and here
is salvador
now salvi hits one into right center
field
that'll get wit to the plate it is 4-3
and the tying run is on and now it's
andrew benintendi
he got him michael fulmer
gets the job done and the tigers boast
their second series sweep of the year
what a job by michael fulmer comes in
three pitches